we're asked to determine for each x
value whether it is in the domain of f
or not and they have our definition of f
of x up here so pause this video and see
if you can work through this before we
do it together
all right so just as a bit of a review
if x is
in the domain of our function that means
that if we input our x into our function
then we are going to get a legitimate
output f of x but if for whatever reason
f isn't defined at x or if it gets some
kind of
undefined state well then it is then x
would not be in the domain
so let's try these different values is x
equal negative 5 in the domain of f
let's see what happens if we try to
evaluate f of negative five
well then we in the numerator we get
negative five
plus five every place where we see an x
we replace it with a negative five
so it's negative five plus five
over
negative 5 minus 3 which is equal to in
our numerator we get 0 and our
denominator we get negative 8.
now at first you see the 0 you might get
a little bit worried but it's just a 0
in the numerator so this whole thing
just evaluates to a zero which is a
completely legitimate output so x equals
negative five is in the domain
what about x equals zero is that in the
domain pause the video see if you can
figure that out
well f of 0 is going to be equal to in
our numerator we have 0 plus 5. in our
denominator we have 0 minus 3. well
that's just going to get us 5 in the
numerator and negative 3 in the
denominator this would just be negative
five thirds but this is a completely
legitimate output so the function is
defined at x equals zero so it's in the
domain for sure
now what about x equals three pause the
video try to figure that out
well i'll do that up here f of 3 is
going to be equal to what and you might
already see some warning signs as to
what's going to happen here in the
denominator but i'll just evaluate the
whole thing in the numerator we get 3
plus 5 in the denominator we get 3 minus
3.
so this is going to be equal to eight
over zero
now what is eight divided by zero well
we don't know this is one of those
fascinating things in mathematics we
haven't defined what happens when
something is divided by zero so 3 is not
in the domain
the function is not defined
there not in domain let's do another
example
determine for each x value whether it's
the whether it is in the domain of g or
not so pause this video and try to work
through all three of these
all right so first of all when x equals
negative 3 do we get a legitimate g of x
so let's see g of negative 3 if we try
to evaluate that's going to be the
square root of 3 times negative 3
which is equal to the square root of
negative 9.
well we with just a principle square
root like this we don't know how to
evaluate this so this is
not in the domain
what about when x equals 0 well g of 0
is going to be equal to
the square root of 3 times 0 which is
equal to the square root of 0 which is
equal to 0 so that gave us a legitimate
result so that is in the domain and what
about g of 2 or x equals 2 what does
that give us a legitimate g of 2
well g of 2 is going to be equal to the
square root of 3 times 2 which is equal
to the square root of 6
which is a legitimate output so x equals
2 is
in the domain
let's do one last example
so we're told this is h of x right over
here and once again we have to figure
out whether these x values are in the
domain or not pause this video and see
if you can work through that
all right well let's just first think
about h of negative 1 what's that going
to be equal to
negative 1 every place we see an x we're
going to replace it with a negative 1
minus 5
squared
well this is going to be equal to
negative 6 squared
negative 6 squared which is equal to
positive 36 which is a very legitimate
output and so this is definitely in the
domain
what about 5 so h of 5 is going to be
equal to 5 minus 5 squared now you might
be getting worried because you're seeing
a 0 here but it's not like we're trying
to divide by zero we're just squaring
zero which is completely legitimate so
zero squared is just a zero and so h of
five is very much defined so this is in
the domain
now what about h of 10
well h of 10 is going to be equal to 10
minus 5 squared which is equal to 5
squared which is equal to 25 once again
it's a very legitimate output so the
function is definitely defined for x
equals 10 and we're done